okay so coming from tonight a in
Slovenia what was your favorite what and
well now we know this what was your
favorite and least favorite scene in
HBO's Game of Thrones my favorite scene
well this of course I suppose everybody
seen this series now I don't worry about
giving things away but my favorite scene
had to be the band a book end of episode
9 the execution of of Ned I thought they
did that very powerfully it was you know
not precisely as described in the books
but it was certainly moving and
evocative the director did a great job
on that the script writers did a great
job
they added a wonderful grace note which
is when when that is being led up to the
stairs where he he sees Aria and he says
to yeren of the Nights Watch as he
passes and he says bail or to set in
motion urine saving Aria which is not in
the books in the book sure and just
sponsor on his own and takes his own
initiative but it was a great idea to
give that little moment then one last
kind of heroic act by by Ned so I love
that I love what they did with that
moment but there were a lot of great
scenes that I love the the final scene
with Dany the season closing episode you
know which I was in considerable
trepidation about because you know how
good were the dragons going to be that's
a big CGI thing and we're you know it's
a it's a reality of television today
that television has become so good and
the technical standards of television of
it come so good that a large portion of
the audience is judging us on the basis
of what they're seeing on major motion
pictures so we always have to to run the
risk of a you know if we do see GOI
people say well it's not as good as well
I saw in Lord of the Rings or or in the
latest you know big-budget science
fiction picture that's so frustrating
because of course those shows have
immensely more time than we
do and they have budgets that are ten
twenty a hundred times our budget and
you know there was a time when the
audience made that distinction they did
not expect the a chase scene on an
episode of TJ Hooker to match what they
would see in Bullitt or or the French
Connection or or you know a major motion
picture cop scene at the time but now
they do expect it and it's a it's a
challenge for our special effects guys
and our technical guys to live up to we
have a very sizable budget for for a
television show but it's still a
television budget and it's not a feature
film budget so we're always having to
wrestle with that least favorite scene
you know I don't I don't know that I
really have one I suppose my least
favorite scene that actually appeared on
on-camera would be the the hunting scene
where Robert is is boar hunting because
you know there was like Robert and Renly
embarrassed and we're sort of tromping
through the woods alone and I talked to
Dan and Davidson you know there should
be like hundred other guys and horses
and tents and when they King goes
something it's not like okay I'm walking
through the woods with a spear here and
you know they don't disagree with that I
mean they said yeah we would have liked
all that stuff too but once again its
budget you know we had an hour to shoot
that scene and we we our horse budget
was exhausted for the season so there we
were so you know it's the realities I
mean the great thing about writing books
as I as I do now is that my budget is
unlimited I can I can write anything
that I can think of and I'm limited by
the size of my imagination and by the
size of the imagination of my readers
but when you translate it to television
and film
you have the realities not only of the
budget which I've mentioned but also the
shooting schedule you know you have to
keep on schedule and
and if you have a lot of trouble getting
the scene you were supposed to shoot in
the morning that gives you less time to
shoot the scene in the afternoon but you
can't slop over to the next day or you
start getting a rolling effect and you
fall forward further and further behind
your shooting schedule and then you're
you're more and more over budget that it
become becomes a mess so all of that
impacts - and this is all the kind of
behind the scenes
I don't know technical stuff that really
the viewers should not have to worry
about it's the viewers really should
just have to view the final product but
nonetheless for those of us concerned
with behind the scenes stuff it's a
reality of life well the actual thing I
mean for the most part I loved all the
scenes that were in the books that they
translated to the TV show I think they
did all of those great I also loved the
vast majority of the new scenes that
they did if I have any quibbles with the
show it it and they are quibbles very
minor thing it was the missing scenes
the scenes that weren't there at all as
I as I watched the show you know
frequently I would find myself thinking
oh okay now they're getting up to this
scene that's really good I can't oh they
didn't have that scene they skipped over
that scene and some of them were scenes
that I had seen the actors do in
auditions they had been scenes that
actually had helped the actors get their
roles so I really expected them because
I already knew all the actor will do
this great I saw them do it in audition
you know sitting in a in a room in front
of a curtain and now I'm gonna get to
see them doing in costume on the set and
and oh it's not there so I would have
loved to have two more hours to have a
12-episode season instead of ten and of
course to have you know an extra fifty
million dollars but but who of us
wouldn't want an extra fifty million
dollars